hello friends I'm Dave and I'm Kate and
we're here to tell you all about 2015's
biggest gaming moments as Lucy's off
stuffing herself with Christmas pudding
and reindeer meat 2015 has been a huge
year for games and we're going to
attempt to distill it down to the best
of the best stories releases and events
from the surprising to the saddening so
can we fit a whole year in two minutes
yeah probably let's go we began 2015 all
sweaty with excitement for kojima and
del Torres pant wetting Lee scary silent
Hills at the last year's creeps and
playable teaser but in early 2015 konami
broke the news and the hearts of
millions of Silent Hill fans that the
game was cancelled which didn't help
with the already circulating rumor that
kajima was leaving the studio months
later with more twists and turns than a
metal gear game we found out the Konami
LA has closed down and the Kajima would
be leaving shortly after one of the
year's saddest reveals came one of the
most surprising the reveal of ukulele
the spiritual successor to banjo kazooie
and a crowdfunding campaign that became
the biggest earning UK videogame
kickstarter amassing more than two
million pounds which is enough to buy
nearly 13,000 chameleons or three
thousand bats bats are expensive
and speaking of game reveals III was
packed with them crammed closer together
than Assassin's Creed fans at a
four-hour q forgive us for lumping them
all into one but you know we only have
two minutes Shenmue 3 Last Guardian
fallout 4 rare replay Gears of War Mass
Effect Andromeda Mirror's Edge catalyst
doomed Dishonored 2 dark souls 3 final
fantasy 7 and loads more it's pretty
good year when a list of reveals is so
long you don't actually have time to
mention all of them the fezzes III
conference was so densely packed with
announcements and the kind of audience
reactions normally reserved for Zelda
games that it deserves to be discussed
on its own but what impressed us most
was the time between the reveal of
fallout 4 and it actually being in our
hands and hearts it was just six short
months even though they might have felt
a lot longer between the reveal and the
release and it's incredible that
Bethesda managed to keep the secret
mostly under wraps for four years before
the official announcement too and then
of course those six months were printed
cryptic campaigns endless merchandising
teaser trailer upon teaser trailer and
more mad theories in a crackpot
conventions newsletter it's possibly one
of the most impressive and cleverly
marketed campaigns we've seen in a while
and we're including Star Wars and their
branded oranges in that GG Bethesda so
those are our biggest moments this year
from the world of gaming Lucy will be
back after the holidays and we hope you
have a great one too before we go though
one last moment and one we wish we
didn't have to mention 2015 was the year
we lost Satoru Iwata a visionary games
executive revered by his peers and fans
alike he led Nintendo through some of
its toughest times overseeing the
release of the DS and the wii which
became so successful at one stage din
Tendo was the second richest corporation
in japan he made in tender bolder more
interesting and is full of joy as ever
Thank You mr. owatta
you